في مرحبًا أمريكا
بالأمس ، قد يكون دونالد ترامب
الرئيس الخامس والأربعين للولايات المتحدة
واليوم الكثير منكم خائفون
ويسيرون في الشوارع ، فأنت قلق من
أن بلدك في يد
هذا الرجل الذي لا يمكن التنبؤ به ولكن لا تقلق ،
فهذا ليس الاسترخاء.  لقد حصلت على هذا
الطعام سيجعل كل شيء على ما يرام ، أعدك
بأننا سنعتني بأمريكا ، إنها
أغلى شيء اشتريناه على الإطلاق
دونالد ، فلنتحدث مع أصدقائه أنك لست ذاهبًا
لرجل بداية رائع اعتقدت أنك
ستكون كذلك  أفضل في هذا ، لكنني سعيد
برؤية الكثير من الأشخاص الذين حضروا
حفل
تنصيبك ، انتظر ، هذه مسيرة المرأة هنا هي
الافتتاح وليست yesh التي كانت ترتدي
هذا الزي على شكل Kelly and Conway ،
أعني هل تعمل من أجلك أم هي
عقد الباب أمام الناس الذين هم
لك والذين يعرفون يومًا ما
يمكن أن تكون بلدك سعيدة كما نحن هنا في
روسيا ، فنحن لسنا منقسمين كما تعلم
مثلك لأن كل
شعبنا غير منقسم مثلك لأن جميع
شعبنا سعداء جدًا  ل  IR
حريات لذا فإن أمريكا ستكون
أربع سنوات طويلة بالنسبة للكثيرين ولكن تذكر
أننا في هذا معًا
[موسيقى]